hello who went to welcome to this video
playing a cowboy in the house for a
scotch no he doesn't play the Scotch
what happens here he usually does it
just plays things Scottish normally okay
here I think d5 must be good it's
usually believed to be good against an
early c3 and this should be pretty nice
actually like the pawn or d3 looks weak
I it's coming with a six maybe huh 97 86
like b6 bishop t5 looking weird but
might be might be ok now can I think I
have to go anyway or a 695 a b7 group p
8 that looks really strange ok
and do you fry okay it gets rid of his
weakness that that's not bad and now
pawn takes I guess screen takes 95 looks
really weird wow I'm really surprised
here because with this development that
depth it looks that looks pretty pretty
awful okay um let's see 93 maybe let's
jump in prevent all kinds of moves 92
and so on okay TM he allows me to take
that pawn I understand them but i think
i'll just i'll take it anyway okay yeah
and i cannot take a five unfortunately
but this is good looking at the week c3
porn
yeah he has a hard time with this night
on v1 maybe night a three still the ship
shakes 95 something like this no ok go
here threatening Bishop d3 now it's not
a big threat should be three hoops you
one probably still ok
now maybe maybe still looks pretty okay
I was thinking that this could be a good
move here gaining a temple Bishop takes
Knight takes is good Bishop c2 I have 93
at least maybe something better but it's
pretty awkward for white to play this
position just see six or something
better okay
hmm yeah do I have to maybe come on
tactics the week back rank I cannot
believe there is no tactic here that at
least gives me a good game
let's see anything
man back rank is also slightly weak him
yeah this is very lame very lame yeah
but g3 wasn't the best problem he put
himself into self pin here but it wasn't
a perfect pin oh my goodness
yeah it's still not easy for wide going
for 93 m check time working I still have
a pretty nice initiative am just isn't
clear with some leading to much i can
get the night day of it doesn't help
doesn't really help I this one maybe
before Luke g1 the night f3 this is a
threat actually okay threatening made
now night a three-year look f1 rookie 14
made
hmm I don't see how we defense it I
found something there's no me di don't
believe this nonsense check there is no
maid I cannot take I cannot take this
it's a it's a it's a bloody pin ah wow
this is so terribly bad that was a
completely winning position here out of
the opening came so let's see how I
screwed up Joe the arrow key 6 is really
lame it's pretty it's pretty good it's
pretty good but yeah c5 was far too
quickly played I just blown at that pawn
I mean it still is dangerous for him but
somehow check its it's amazing that that
that widest is surviving this kind of
thing here I be sure before it's just
saving him it's just saving him
check yeah there is no there is no way i
can go it also doesn't help yeah bishops
III is also the immediate I mean a pin
myself so it's quite remarkable really
thinking that it should be good for
black with the night coming to air 30
Knight e5 is actually ok at least don't
don't understand what's the difference
to be honest then I do this this what is
the difference here I can just take the
pawn ok they are complicated but this is
this position out of the opening is just
so bad for white rupee it up to him I'm
completely playing the engine moose and
then maybe maybe this is too too slow or
anything I don't know engine is on minus
one constantly
and 95 maybe that is better that's given
by the comp threatening 93 I couldn't
really I didn't think that this was so
much helping him but it does help white
that 86 stuff yeah maybe this is better
for 93 computer wants to do this and
this minus one yeah I probably will win
some kind of pony due to the activity
Jim your queen d 4 is an amazing move he
has to just take with the pawn and the
position is kind of okay and after that
it's very obvious that black is clearly
better but okay what can you do it okay
thanks for watching